[Musique]
bienvenue à la maison musée raymond
devos
[Musique]
c'est dans cette maison que raymond
devos a vécu pendant plus de 40 ans 43
ans ils ont acheté cette maison avec sa
femme simone en 1962 ils sont installés
en 1963 et ils y sont restés jusqu'à la
fin de leur vie donc raymond devos est
décédé en 2006 c'était son souhait que
cette maison devienne une fondation et
devienne un musée et du coup c'est ce
qui s'est passé le musée ouvert en 2016
donc ici à saint rémy les chevreuse
[Musique]
ici on est dans son salon ce qui était
son salon avec quelques éléments
d'origine vous avez le sol et puis vous
avez aussi cette bibliothèque qui a été
fait par lui qui à la fin d'un petit
théâtre de la commedia dell arte et vous
retrouvez une petite partie de ces
livres et notamment vous retrouvez aussi
son meilleur ami georges brassens
ici vous avez quelques jouets du monde
du cirque raymond devos a découvert le
cirque quand il était enfant à l'âge de
4-5 ans avec son père et ses frères il
s'en est jamais remis il aimait tout
dans le cirque et notamment les
disciplines sportives du cirque il a
beaucoup pratiqué ces disciplines et en
fait raymond devos était un homme assez
sportif malgré son apparence et il a il
a beaucoup pratiqué il était funambule
il marcher sur les mains jusqu'à plus de
40 ans et il a fait du trampoline
jusqu'à 80 ans
voilà ça l'à beaucoup saluent a beaucoup
servi aussi dans son art sur scène
ici on retrouve
derrière le rideau la loge de raymond
devos avec toutes ces affaires
reconstitué à l'identique
raymond devos était très ritualisé avant
de monter sur scène il est très anxieux
il avait un trac immense c'était très
important pour lui d'avoir toutes ces
affaires positionner comme ça et
notamment dans cette boîte avec ses nez
de clown il avait un petit rituel c'est
qu'il fallait essayer les signer avant
de choisir lequel était le bon pour le
spectacle du soir alors qu'ils sont tous
identiques
[Musique]
ici on est dans la salle de musique avec
tous les instruments dont raymond devos
jouait sur scène il était passionné par
les instruments de musique la musique a
toujours fait partie de sa vie depuis
qu'il était enfant grâce à ses parents
lui ces trois instruments préférés
c'était la guitare la clarinette et le
piano est ce qu il adorait aussi avec
les instruments de musique c'est elle et
bricoler les tordre un peu dans tous les
sens et donc notamment vous avez 7
clarinette molle qui est une clarinette
fabriqué avec un tuyau d'arrosage en
caoutchouc et puis aussi ce cor de
chasse qui était né d'une boutade de
georges brassens qui en parlant de
quelqu'un d'autre disait qu'il avait un
souffle a déroulé un cor de chasse du
coup raymond devos s'était dit comment
est ce qu'on peut transformer ça en
quelque chose d'intéressant et donc il a
pris un pavillon une embouchure et les a
reliées par un câble de gazinière pas en
doré
on est ici dans le grenier raymond devos
était sa pièce son espace son antre en
fait et y venez ici pour créer pour ce
faire des journées entières
de création et vous retrouver en fait
tout son bazar créatif qui était
essentiel pour lui la voir sous les yeux
c'était très important pour partie comme
ils disaient partir du sol du quotidien
pour ensuite s'élever dans l'imaginaire
raymond devos en fait c'est un homme
passionné qui émettent ou tout
l'intéressait tous venez nourrir son
univers son imaginaire il aurait voulu
avoir plusieurs vies en fait il estimait
que sa vie était trop courte il aurait
voulu tout apprendre et notamment les
instruments de musique raymond devos est
un musicien mais c'était aussi un
écrivain un humoriste un circassien il
était tout ça à la fois et on l'oublié
parfois parce que tous à sa forme est en
fait la totalité de son imaginaire
[Musique]